[Musique]
dans le cadre du partenariat de
proximité d'action sociale le
département et le ccas de saint paul est
organisé au village corail une matinée
dédiée à la prévention des chutes pour
les personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans on
a un public et commun donc au
département et au ccas par le biais des
des aides ménagères en fait une haine
qui est proposée par le département
donc on a dans un premier temps donc
contacté
ces bénéficiaires pour savoir un peu
qu'elle était
le thème qui leur parlera est le plus
qui livre est plus intéressant pour eux
d'aborder donc suite à ça en avouant
voyez donc des invitations à ces
personnes qui ont répondu présentes
aujourd'hui trois ateliers ont été
proposés aux participants exercice de
relevage gymnastique douce ou encore
présentation de matériel technique
l'atelier que nous proposons aujourd'hui
c'est pour montrer le relevage des
personnes dans une suite principalement
donc à la maison au jour avec ces
techniques que je montre donc on voit
que il ya effectivement des gestes qui
peuvent perdre en capacité dont quand on
est âgé donc là je leur montre les
techniques colons pour se régler plus
facilement et en faisant le moindre
effort possible on nous a proposé de
faire petit atelier l'activité histoire
de montrer que ce même c'était un âge
qu'on peut rester en alerte
on peut faire du sport je te ment pour
justement protéger un petit peu leur
santé une matinée très enrichissante et
de précieux conseils pour ces personnes
vivent parfois seuls ou étant isolé
c'est qu'on vienne intéressant c'est que
les personnes âgées tout seul pour moi
car faire des monstres action l hépatite
on pas ainsi dans sa voix j'ai tout
enlevé les fesses je suis à la tête et
tu peux rêver
ces packs sont les mots qui appelle
quelqu'un pour te donner un petit bout
de match
des ateliers qui permettent aux
personnes âgées de se maintenir le plus
possible dans leur autonomie le
département et le ccas souhaite
renouveler cette action
[Musique]